Drew Barrymore opens up about sex
explaining why she hasn't been in an
intimate relationship for years a lot of
my life has been an open book but let
that be a Liberation the talk show host
gets candid in a new blog post revealing
that she hasn't been intimate since her
2016 split from her ex-husband will
copelman the former couple shares two
daughters ten-year-old Olive and
eight-year-old Frankie families are many
different definitions in this day and
age and Drew says she feels a lot of
responsibility as their mom quote after
two kids and a separation from their
father that has made me cautious I have
had the pleasure of Shifting my focus
when it comes to love for myself and my
two daughters the one thing I try to
nail is that if my kids come first
everything else no matter what no matter
what hot mess it is it'll it'll be okay
because the kids came first will has
since remarried director of fashion
development Alexandra Mickler but Drew
writes that getting back into a romance
has not been her priority quote since
entering Life as a single mom I have not
been able to have an intimate
relationship instead the actress says
she's had the honor and pleasure to work
on herself and she's raising her girls
to be empowered and to love themselves I
just spend every waking moment with them
I wake up with them I go to sleep with
them I have my weekends with them like I
work hard and I work crazy hours but
there's also a lot of down time and I
just give every moment to them
quote I am someone who is deeply
committed to fostering how young girls
my daughters and myself as a woman are
supposed to function in this world a
relationship with a man has not been top
of mind for me for a very long time
Drew's blog post comes on the heels of
some comments she recently made about
sex on her daytime talk show it all
stemmed from a discussion surrounding
Andrew Garfield who revealed he
abstained from sex for six months to
prep for his role as a Jesuit priest in
the 2016 film silence I was celibate for
six months I wow I was um I you know and
fasting a lot I had some pretty wild
trippy experiences from starving myself
of sex and food for that period of time
what's wrong with me that six months
doesn't seem like a very long time I was
like yeah so Drew says she was inspired
to clarify that comment on her blog
after some fans interpreted her words as
Drew hates sex quote for the record I do
not hate sex I have just finally come to
the Epiphany that love and sex are
simply not the same thing
[Music]
thank you